if you're stuck in your business then
this video will help you get unstuck
so this morning i was reached out to by
a business owner who's doing about one
and a half million dollars a month
in revenue and he was like hey man i'm
kind of stuck doing what i'm doing and i
just don't know anyone who's in my space
who does more than two million dollars a
month he's in the online marketing space
and i thought that was really
interesting and we had a good
conversation about it and so i wanted to
share
um what we talked about and so the first
thing is i
completely oppose that viewpoint and i
think this is so interesting because the
reason we get stuck in our business is
because we
either have a belief that is incorrect
we there's this character trait that we
lack
where there's a skill deficiency we
don't know how to do what we need to do
we don't know how to be who we need to
be
we don't believe what we need to believe
right that's what we think about the
world and so whenever i'm looking at a
business
or business owner or myself and i'm
stuck at a certain level i think is this
a belief that i'm lacking
or that that's wrong is it a trait that
i have
that i need or i need to change or is
there a skill right
and a lot of times it depends on who
you're talking to but you need all three
and a lot of people who are just really
good at character development only talk
about traits people are really good at
skill development only talk about skills
and people who are kind of like a little
bit more woo and they talk about beliefs
but you need all three right
and so when i was talking to this guy he
said you know no one's in the online
space making more than two million
dollars a month
and i thought this was interesting
because when i came into the gym space
with our first company there was no one
who's making more than three million
dollars a year
in that space and um for those who don't
know you know we grew that company to 30
million
a year plus and so we 10xed what the
biggest person in the space was doing at
the time
and so a lot of that's kind of like
running the four-minute mile for the
first time is like
just because no one has done it doesn't
mean it's not possible and so you know
for this
individual i was like we'll break it
down to physics right break it down like
tell me why
you think that you can't get past
that no one excuse me that no one can
get past 2 million a month
like why is there not enough customers
right and he's mass market so of course
there's enough customers
it's like so so tell me like why can you
not do it
right as we're talking about this i want
you to think like think about your
business right
um i get research all the time like hey
i'm doing
you know two million dollars a year i'm
doing 5 million a year i'm doing 10
million a year
i just don't think we can grow any
bigger within our market now
there are real market constraints right
so for example if you were if you were
serving chiropractors and there's 50 000
chiropractors in the united states
if you had all 50 000 of them then yes
you wouldn't be able to grow
in that space and then at that point you
could grow adjacent and so then at that
point your business would still would
continue to grow and it's normal for
businesses to go vertical to vertical
and expand uh horizontally in that way
but in
if you're in a mass market business or a
business that serves consumers in any
any way
the entire marketplace is your base and
so when he said that he doesn't know
anyone who's doing over two million
dollars a month
that is a belief issue right i'm like
well let me give you this one to think
with
well if you have 10 competitors and each
of them are doing 2 million
a month then it means that one of you
could be better than all of you and make
20 million
a month say with that for a second think
about it because when i
when i looked at the gym space when i
got into the very beginning i looked at
all of the people who were out there and
i saw that all of them were doing one to
three million
a year and so i was like if i'm better
than all of them then i should be able
to do 30 million i should be able to add
up all of their businesses and that
should be what my business should be
able to do
and so if you think about like that like
it is a hundred percent that way how
much do people spend
on logistics and you know fulfillment
right how much do people spend in
consumer can you imagine
jeff bezos like in the in the early days
of amazon thinking to himself like well
like you just can't get past 10 million
a year just can't get past 100 million
a year like there are so many people the
reason that people get limited is
because of their beliefs
and the reality is because they don't
have one of those three things and so
with this individual
i first started with the belief i said
do you believe it's possible
that you can get there because like if
we don't have that then nothing can
happen right and so i was like well
let's just add up all your competitors
is there any reason that you couldn't
just get all of their revenue
right i was like well no okay cool so
that one's done traits
well this one is like are you are you
patient enough to see it out
um with which and part of that comes to
the fact of like if you believe you're
making a positive impact right you
believe that your product or service
really is benefiting the world which is
honestly what i think one of the biggest
issues is a lot of people don't really
genuinely when they look at themselves
in the mirror at night
believe that the product is good enough
and so subconsciously they do not push
it
further than to meet their own
individual needs think about that for a
second
like if you if you've matched your own
individual like you've
you've capped out your ability to spend
money and and
like your ability to generate money the
only reason to make more money past that
if you're a self-aware individual is
because you
actually believe the thing that you have
is going to help more people and so it
shifts from being a self-centered focus
to another center-focused
process right and so that person may not
have the traits or the
like to have that like to do that right
and the third is like he might not be
able to grow
because he lacks the skills like he
might not have the skills of
of recruiting somebody to uh open a new
sales channel right
he might not have the skill himself to
do it or the skill to find someone
because those are two different ways to
think about it like you can always
acquire the skill which is how do i do
it uh or you can have the you know
probably the wealthier mindset of like
well who can do this
right and so then you can make you can
approach that but as long as you know
what needs to happen then you can find
the who
now if you are completely unaware
because i get this question all the time
like what at what point do i
bring someone in to like run my business
for me so i had someone asked me this
yesterday they were making i think like
50 or 100
a month i can't remember what it was and
i was like dude like you're just
starting
you don't even mean like you're just
getting into the game like
what's the you know i mean like you
don't need to have like is your market
capped is there a reason that you like
why do you want to do this
right and i think it's because they
didn't really believe in the thing right
that they're selling
because if you believe in the thing then
you want to you want to be the one who's
driving it you know and continuing to
grow it over time so anyways all that to
say
right now if you're stuck right or you
perceive yourself to be stuck i would
break down is there an
actual cap on how big my market is right
and have i sold 100 of my marketplace i
sold 30
of my marketplace and if you're in like
the one percent of your marketplace or
half a percent of your marketplace or
0.1 percent of your marketplace
you haven't capped your market you just
have capped your skill
or your beliefs or your traits and so
then
i would look at okay well if all my
competitors are doing this put together
then there's no reason i can't get
all of that or half of that if i were
way better than all of them right
if you were better because each one of
those businesses has a specific way they
acquire customers a specific way of
fulfilling those customers
right and so if you knew how to do each
one of those things and you did it
better than them then there's no reason
that you couldn't beat them
right and so if you think about that
then then all of a sudden that should
break the limit that you have on how
much you can actually make within your
current vehicle
then you get forced to look at the other
two which is like is there a trait that
i lack
or is it a skill that i lack uh in
getting to where i want to go and so
this was the conversation i had with him
at the end of the conversation like wow
i guess i can
get this thing to 10 million a month etc
and i was like right and so um that was
the entire purpose of this video is that
if you are stuck
and you are thinking that you are capped
you might be
but it's not because your market
oftentimes it's because of your beliefs
a trait or a skill that you lack and
then figuring out which one it is and
then attacking it is usually the way to
go through it so anyways hope you found
value in this video keeping awesome hope
you like my mobile studio setup
we are we're rocking the colorado
mountains it's beautiful up here and i
hope you guys uh
are having an amazing day catch you guys
soon bye